it's the UK's biggest hospital with
eventual capacity for 4,000 covered 19
patients built inside a London
conference centre it took just nine days
to construct with the help of Army
engineers dramatically expanding the
critical care bed count and other
similar sites are underway Prince
Charles Cup the virtual ribbon from his
Scottish residence having recovered from
a bout of coronavirus the creation of
this hospital is above all the results
of an extraordinary collaboration and
partnership between NHS managers the
military and all those involved to
create a center on a scale that has
never been seen before in the United
Kingdom someone who hasn't yet recovered
is Boris Johnson due back at work today
a week after announcing he'd got the
virus Johnson still has a temperature so
there was another video message instead
as a haggard looking Prime Minister
continues to self isolate inside Downing
Street I still have one of the symptoms
of - symptom of I have a temperature and
so in accordance with government advice
I must continue myself isolation until
that symptom itself goes the Prime
Minister's call was amplified by the
Health Minister who earlier warned the
UK peak may arrive sooner than expected
perhaps within the next few weeks and
work continues just about everywhere to
prepare for it here in Northwest London
the grim business of setting up a
temporary morgue beside a crematorium
you can just make out the twin peaks of
two refrigerated structures above the
fence over there London accounts for
around a third of the UK's total numbers
of infections
deaths and new research by scientists at
Imperial College suggest the actual
London numbers could be much higher than
advertised
researchers say that huge gaps in
testing capacity that the government is
now trying to close plus high numbers of
very mild or asymptomatic cases mean
that one in 15 Londoners or around
600,000 people may have or have had the
disease that's 60 times more than the
number of registered cases in London
extrapolate that across the country and
the spread of coronavirus appears far
wider than anyone thought Jonah hull
al-jazeera London